ils laissent derrière eux un pays en
guerre
sans se retourner
le président polonais vient à leur
rencontre et échanges avec certains
d'entre eux derrière un cordon de
sécurité imposant à elles seules la
pologne accueille plus de la moitié des
réfugiés ukrainien en europe soit
environ 650 mille personnes quelle
classe jin kym highroad a comme ça
telecel factories casero nasa telle
était la daube révolte chez procter
occasion le dr laetitia bien
dormi shaibu jeune agresseur ouvre aussi
novak y roumanie ou ici en hongrie plus
d'un million deux cent mille ukrainiens
ont déjà fui leur pays pour l'europe
[Musique]
my friends and family country
de
profonds
l'écrasante majorité des ukrainiens qui
fuit sont des femmes et des enfants les
hommes ont été réquisitionnés pour
combattre tandis qu'ils fuient la guerre
un autre fléau menace la famille
ce vendredi joe biden a téléphoné au
président polonais pour le remercier
d'avoir accueillis et aidés geler
réfugiés nucléaire